les spectateurs ont répondu présents
mais sans se presser chacun à son rythme
comme si après deux ans de pandémie il
fallait réapprendre à fêter ensemble
c'est la première fois qu'on l'a mené
vers 20h15 avait donc c'est important
pour nous pour ses grands parents qui
habitent la colombie c'est un moment de
retrouvailles longuement attendu c'est
important d'être ici quand même oui très
important oui pourquoi parties avaient
tous les maux canadien c'est très bon
pour nous c'est aussi le retour des
traditions mais le mahb à chicago mais
quoi et le temps d'apporter des
nouveautés à la cérémonie pour la
première fois les célébrations se sont
ouvertes par un moment de réflexion avec
les communautés autochtones
je suis très heureux d'être en famille
avec vous célébrez la fête du canada
cette année en personne
ce contact en personne le premier
ministre trudeau visiblement heureux de
le retrouver c'est vraiment l'esprit de
pouvoir se revoir de pouvoir serrer des
mains de pouvoir sa cote et les gens
contre les autres
sur scène il a le blanc ne boude pas son
plaisir de renouer avec le public
[Musique]
pour la chanteuse manitobaine d'origine
ukrainienne chantal kreviazuk c'est un
moment précieux une occasion unique et
touchant d'exprimer le soutien du canada
à l'ukraine on est ici et on ne va pas
changer notre position on est ici pour
vous et on ne va pas partir en guerre
[Musique]
malgré une foule clairsemée l'énergie ne
manquent pas tant dans le public que sur
scène
mais c'est impossible pour justin
trudeau d'ignorer les divisions les
séparent la gestion de la pandémie et
les manifestations que cela engendre
pour ceux qui se sentent un petit peu
frustré par rapport à ce qu'on a dû
faire en tant que pays pendant les
dernières années on va rester ouvert
qu'on passionnés
c'est pour ce sens 55e anniversaire du
canada en a mis l'accent sur la
diversité et l'inclusion
le défi post pandémie sera de rétablir
l'unité au pays ici valérie gamache
radio canada ottawa